Let's answer our NUMA
memory allocation quiz.
In order to improve
performance of a NUMA machine,
the operating system should really put
all data pages that are mostly accessed
by a single core in the memory
slice local to that core.
That will ensure that most of
the accesses by each of the cores
are going to the local memory.
Which both makes sure that accesses will
be quicker than they otherwise would be
and also the network will not be
used for the majority of accesses.
So this should be selected.
If we, however, put all data pages ever
touched by core N in the memory slice N,
then we have a problem because, for
example, one core might initialize all
the data, and then we put all
of the data in its memory slice.
And at that point, that memory slice
becomes the bottleneck because
everybody will be accessing that slice,
and the data might not even fit there.
So this is not a correct answer.
And then put the stack pages for
core N in the memory slice N
is a very extreme example of this where
really it will just be the core N
that is ever accessing this data, so of
course it should be in its memory slice.
So the stack is one of those things
that the operating system can figure
out very easily where to put.
Some of the other pages are a little
bit more difficult because
more than one core are accessing it.
And then the operating system
needs to choose a good location
either because one core is accessing
it more than others, or to put it in
a memory module that is kind of close
to all the cores that are accessing it.